[Music]
breaking news yeah
he's one of our very own spies who
steals from you when he flies I speak of
Britain Sam Brinton and he likes his
luggage stolen not stored
got one laugh new internal documents
reveal Sam Brenton Biden's sticky
fingered ex-nuclear energy official was
traveling on a secret taxpayer-funded
trip when he allegedly stole a woman's
suitcase and contents worth nearly four
grand in Nevada
yep he's like a non-binary double agent
putting the bond in bondage
no fan of word play here huh
oh man and you and me paid for the whole
trip the whole thing brinton's Vegas
trip happened in summer 2022 but it
wasn't until December when he was
charged with grand larceny and he lived
high on the hog metaphorically staying
at a Hilton on the Vegas Strip and
racking up almost two granted charges
that we again ended up paying for one
could say he lived like a king and a
queen
so he was on some sort of top secret
mission but instead of a license to Kill
he had a license to steal girdles and
leggings he looks like a kid with chemo
who just mugged Mrs Roper
wow I know but he had some great gadgets
too bulletproof lip gloss and a wrist
watch that could tell him where the
closest brunch was can you imagine what
kind of spy Brenton would make don't
scoff in this day and age maybe Sam
Brinton is our new James Bond God knows
we hate the old racist sexist one maybe
it's time for a new 007 and it's double
O creepy
saving America isn't a job for one man
or one woman it takes someone that can
be both or neither that terrorists would
love to get their hands on nuclear fuel
but they didn't count on this Watchdog
with the help of stolen luggage they is
a Master of Disguise from Los Alamos to
the women's swim team there's no place
they can go they can even infiltrate the
most competent non-senile Administration
we've ever seen they can't put they a
box but can they put they in a jail cell
you've seen they it pronouns are forever
man with the golden gown and your mom's
clothes but this summer Sam Britain is
the they Who Loved Me
foreign
were you surprised to learn he was
living high on the Hog on our dime and
is that so outrageous
just in general you know you just
realize you never know anything about
anyone like you look at this man and you
think what a sensible sane person he
should totally be in charge of our
nuclear uh waste or whatever it was you
know this is just really shock I think
we're all shocked that Batman was not as
stable as he appeared to be no he
doesn't I don't know you know just
because you're unstable that doesn't
mean you steal that's true there's a lot
of unstable people who um no they steal
no they do they're all thieves Jimmy
give it to me so what do you make of
this this guy actually dresses worse
than you do but at least you pay for
your clothes you go to the Goodwill and
you pork down that hard earned three
dollars you got from telling jokes on
the subway you guys are taking a lot of
shots at my designer tonight and uh I'm
Not Really Gonna stick up for him but
his cni dog deserves better than this
um painful here's the thing man
uh it's amazing to think that the one
bag this Administration didn't steal was
cocaine yes you know
but this is like part of the problem
like okay when you talk about him living
high in the hog like for real if we were
going to be constructive he's
technically at the same time flying
every week for this Administration think
of how much money he saved us on baggage
fees that's true it's almost like a push
but this is the problem with identity
politics appointments you can't vet them
because any pushback is you know framed
as bigotry like oh you're against this
weirdo in a dress with a mustache you
must hate these people and you're like
no he has no qualifications for doing
the gig it's like the same thing that
happened with mayor Pete like
traditionally if your nickname is
pothole Pete you don't get left in
charge of every road in America as
Transportation exactly sure it's like
we're going to hire an education
secretary named summer school Steve you
know what I mean and you would if he was
gay because you can't criticize him it's
like you're living you're like this guy
like this guy is there's a difference
between mayor Pete and this fellow this
fell as a complete whack job but he was
living his life In Plain Sight yeah
which made was basically telling you
yeah
keep away yeah can't question me you
know how dare you accuse me of this
think about this would you let that
watch your kids there's no chance but
he's in charge of nuclear waste
management cat what do you make of this
uh this new information as a Libertarian
it must leave you fuming
will taxes do that in general yes I
think it's fine to want to you know
stand out and go against the grain and
clearly this person is in all eyes on me
type of person that's all fine and good
but you can't do that while also wanting
to be the kind of person who wears
stolen clothes right this person is such
a stupid person yeah uh I I don't
understand you have to choose one or the
other either a life of crime
or a life in the public eye right you
can't do crimes in public so Joe Biden
yeah
that may be where he got they got it
from
Rob I don't know if you can't do crimes
to be in the pub I mean he dresses like
the Joker and the Joker right to not get
caught yeah you know what he is he is a
kind of a low rant comic book villain
yeah like the good old days you know I'm
gonna I'm gonna age myself but Batman
you know you had the Riddler he wore a
funny suit yeah the Riddler wore a great
suit you had the Joker obviously which
has been done to death I preferred Cesar
Romero yeah who also I think yes Burgess
Meredith as the penguin he had the
little top hat and a monocle like you
criminals had Flair maybe we're on the
wrong side of this by the way every
single one of those references really
connects to the young people right
that's great wait do my next reference I
just wanted to be I want to be in the
meeting where they say look we got the
secret mission and we need to send
somebody on
to be discreet about it who do we send
on the secret mission how about the guy
in the green lipstick yeah like what
kind of like what you'd think it'd be
the non-descript person you said on the
secret mission and Pam you uh you know
you find something that's more
appropriate for his uh that's the double
agent double think it's like you would
never hide in plain sight hide and play
you would never pick the most
ostentatious attention-seeking person
didn't the CIA used to do that didn't
they used to like use actors and people
that trust too used to oh yeah yeah I
don't think they ever used the guy in a
green dress and lipstick well you know
what but then I don't know I don't know
the history of utia is Mystery to me you
made fun of my references oh do I have
one for you oh really and so I was I
keep looking at Sam Brinton and I'm
trying to figure out who he reminds me
of and then it was it's dawned on me as
a kid this weird comic strip called
Henry did you ever see does anybody
remember Henry Henry yep too bad we
don't have a picture of it because that
would be really helpful Henry like
somebody even the people in the control
room didn't know who I was talking about
I still have no idea here the creepiest
this is the creepiest it was the
creepiest comic book character he was
mute yeah he's young and he was bald but
they drew him like it was Charlie Brown
if he lost his mouth in an accident I
know no it was I I do not understand and
by the way this was older than peanuts
it came out in like 1930. well clearly
he couldn't eat peanuts look at his face
anyway I just feel like it's a you know
he looks a little like a Matt Damon
who's made some very bad Life Choices
yes exactly so that's the map and he has
the map that dude Sam Britton looks like
if the person you'd see the first person
you'd see if you woke up in a basement
with no idea how you got there that's
what he looks like you know that's
always been my dream date that's hot yes
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else